dans les débuts de tpm paix jean michel
se tirer sur l'élastique avant d'aller
en plateau pour avoir des arrivées
descendu j'ai un délire aujourd'hui la
boîte à secrets j'adore parce que vous
savez quoi il met une nouvelle
productrice à vous le savez qui
s'appelle agatha qui travaille avec
stéphane bern l'an dernier et donc c'est
vrai que hanouna stéphane bern j'adore
stéphane mais c'est quand même deux
salles deux ambiances et elle m'écrit
vraiment lorsque je dois dire quand je
vais faire le lancement à la agatha zain
donc voilà ce qu aurait fait stéphane
bern j'ai devant moi une boîte et qui va
mettre la zizanie
chaque chroniqueur a écrit un anonyme en
secret sur un autre chroniqueur premier
secret qu'elle y fait du r dj elle n'en
voit quasiment pas de son dans
l'émission ils sont envoyés depuis la
régie
moi je parie sur jean michel vernhes
exact je ne sais pas lors d'une soirée
tpm paies ta c'est un grand moment
jean michel a fait une photo de groupe
avec cyril et des dirigeants de la
société
sur cette photo sa braguette et est
ouverte et comme il ne portait pas de
slip son sexe pendait dans le club one
way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est des malades
non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
doit-on de jalousie mais c'est pas qui
pendait qui s'est passé dit je croyais
qu'il allait faire du saut à la perche
dans une autre vie syrie les benjamins
on tue la même amoureuse s'est pas
lancée c'est ben haim sa wii ont partagé
un mi-temps en fait un mondial
[Applaudissements]
voici la vérité c'était pas ma meuf
ah ben moi non plus à l'époque de
l'émission célébrités valérie prêté sa
loge à benjamin castaldi pour qu'il
puisse faire ses galipettes à des rôles
c'est votre journée pascal isabelle
morini-bosc un ballon non mais j'aurais
plus ou moins que c'est tout seul mais
c'est moi qui vous ai dénoncé cette
démission
benjamin castaldi piste toujours la
porte ouverte aux loges à ses servants
nationale n'est pas la chasse d'eau
c'est vraiment c'est vrai dans les
débuts de tpm paix jean michel se tirer
sur l'élastique avant d'aller au plateau
pour avoir des arrivées descendu ça
c'est de vous c'est en plus bas une
expression comme ça au leasing scénique
c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit tu répètes de
contrer le compte du toit bahreïn fait
vibrer oui quoi vous êtes visa sur lui
oui merci c'est moi où terme était très
très bien cette fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]